[Musica]
[Applauso]
fin da quando ero bambino mi hanno
insegnato che per avere successo nella
vita
bisognava avere un piano mi dicevano
luca deve avere un piano luca prepara il
tuo piano ci insegnano infatti che la
vita va programmata e da adulti è
diventato indispensabile avere un piano
nel mondo del lavoro
se ci pensiamo infatti nel business ogni
azienda ogni imprenditore ogni grande
innovatore ha un piano che descrive nei
minimi dettagli il successo che andrà a
realizzare tutti loro hanno una cosa in
comune sono convinti che il loro piano
originale li porterà a successo al
raggiungimento di quel traguardo tanto
desiderato tanto sognato
però sappiamo che la realtà è un'altra
infatti di solito si sbagliano tutti e
sì perché quel piano pool preciso
dettagliato che sia difficilmente supera
il confronto con la realtà
quindi a questo punto ciò che separa il
successo dall'insuccesso e la capacità
di far evolvere quel piano e reagire al
fallimento del piano originale
qui abbiamo due tipologie di individui
coloro che nel momento che fallisce il
piano originale si fermano si leccano le
ferite ma si rialzano e continuano
inesorabilmente a implementare lo stesso
identico piano sperando ovviamente di
essere più fortunati questa volta e poi
abbiamo dall'altra parte chi si ferma
evolve cambia e stravolge quel piano
trasformandolo nel piano b se pensiamo
bene tutti i grandi innovatori della
storia se si fossero attenuti al loro
piano originale non avremmo oggi quelle
aziende che consideriamo essere le più
innovative del mercato quelle aziende
che hanno cambiato il nostro modo di
vivere quelle stesse aziende che in
questo momento senza nominarle vi stanno
venendo in mente
proviamo a vedere adesso infatti insieme
qualche realtà che è nata con un'idea
con un piano ben preciso ed oggi però fa
tutt'altro
quindi c'è un sito internet che nacque
con l'idea di creare una piattaforma di
video incontri dove veniva chiesto la
gentil sesso di fare un upload di un
video per 20 dollari nella speranza di
trovare l'anima gemella
ecco questa piattaforma è la più grande
piattaforma al mondo di video gratuiti e
da youtube siamo molto lontani dall'idea
dei fondatori ma vediamo un altro
esempio molto interessante stiamo
parlando di un'azienda che ha più di 100
anni di storia
siamo in giappone e questa azienda nasce
con un piano ben preciso quello di
creare le carte da gioco del famoso
gioco giapponese ana fuda ok è
sconosciuto per noi sicuramente famoso
nel sol levante
però in questi cento anni di storia
questa azienda ha cambiato pelle ha
cambiato i suoi piani e si è trasformata
infatti da produttore di carte da gioco
è diventata un'azienda alimentare
lanciando un inseguendo po un trend del
momento quello della lista noodles avete
presente quei barattolini dove ci sono
dentro i noodles ecco l'idea che hanno
avuto era fare l'istant rais ci poteva
stare perché il mercato tutti i maggiori
zoe quindi alla fine il l'idea era era
centrata però successo non arrivo per
poi evolvere diventare una compagnia di
taxi
forse voleva essere ruber dell'epoca
il mercato non era ancora pronto ecco
che qui anche qui il successo non arrivò
poi cambiò completamente settore e
aprire una catena di hotel per incontri
intimi chiamati i love hotel e qui
nonostante il lato romantico
dell'iniziativa il successo non arriva
infine
inventarono l'idraulico più famoso al
mondo
quell omino che saltava su e giù da vari
tubi delle fognature di new york
beh avete capito di chi sto parlando
sto parlando di supermario questa
azienda e nintendo regina indiscussa
delle console e dei videogame
ma gli esempi sono tantissimi da
cartiera a più grande produttore di
telefonini a quasi non produrli più la
storia di nokia è piena di piani a piani
b e anche altre versioni di piane
avon era un'azienda che vendeva libera a
porta a porta
paypal è nata come un sistema di
crittografia non un sistema di pagamento
tiffany era una cartoleria non faceva
nei gioielli di lusso e neanche offriva
colazione la lezione però è semplice
quello che ci insegnano questi esempi è
che i cambiamenti delle strategie
aziendali non sono delle semplici note a
piè di pagina nella storia di questa
azienda perché questi cambiamenti hanno
creato nuovi scenari nuove opportunità
nuovi modelli di business e impensabili
rimanendo fedeli al piano originale
allora a questo punto la domanda
che
fondamentale è come hanno fatto queste
aziende a passare dal piano ha quindi al
piano originale a modello di business di
successo e sostenibile il piano b e
perché milioni di aziende oggi non ci
riescono falliscono ora prima di
rispondere a questa domanda o provare ad
arrivare una risposta vorrei condividere
con voi un altro settore che quello che
ovviamente mi è molto mi è molto caro
che il settore finanziario
lì ho passato la mia intera esistenza
lavorativa tra banche e società
finanziarie
qui in questo settore fondamentale
scrivere i piani un po perché viene
imposto dal regolatore un po perché ci
serve un piano per raccogliere i
consensi al mercato o raccontare la
nostra strategia
però se guardiamo attentamente questi
piani scopriamo che il piano ha di
solito è un po una copia del piano da
dell'anno prima con qualche
aggiustamento eccetera
non esiste mai un piano b e poi quando
arrivano crisi finanziarie nuovi player
come le finte che che stanno
rivoluzionando questo settore
o il cigno nero del covip
tutti questi piani saltano uno dopo
l'altro e purtroppo anche le società
stesse
vi ho citato le finte che le finte che
sono quelle società che uniscono finanze
tecnologia che hanno un piano ben
preciso quello di ripensare prodotti e
processi nel mondo finanziario e qui
abbiamo l'imbarazzo della scelta
abbiamo chi ci permette di aprire un
conto corrente e meno di otto minuti
senza la sua vita burocrazia che ci dà
la possibilità di avere un credito
istantaneo senza compilare avete
presente quei lunghi formulari attendere
giorni per avere un esito che
addirittura ci trasforma in trader
professionisti perché ci dà la
possibilità di fare trading online un
modo nuovo innovativo e chi invece
addirittura ci attiva delle micro
assicurazioni magari per due giorni o
per brevi ore ben poche ore se però
guardiamo attentamente questo mondo e
queste società scopriamo che
tendenzialmente queste fintec non hanno
inventato nulla eh sì perché è il conto
corrente alla fine il conto corrente la
carte di debito è la carte di debito è
la stessa identica carta che avevate in
tasca 10 anni fa per fare acquisti
quello che hanno fatto quello che era
nel loro piano era rivoluzionare
l'esperienza cliente rendendola
sicuramente più nuova innovativa ma
soprattutto in linea con le aspettative
del cliente di oggi con i bisogni che il
cliente a oggi che non sono più bisogni
di dieci o quindici anni fa forse
neanche quelli un anno fa
ecco che è importante allora capire
perché questi piani aziendali falliscono
perché fallisco in piani aziendali
perché di solito si parte dal
presupposto che tutto sia già noto ho
conosciuto in anticipo ma il futuro è
imprevedibile
lo sappiamo benissimo è un piano non
potrà prevedere ciò che è imprevedibile
per eccellenza il futuro un famoso
comandante della seconda guerra mondiale
douglas mcarthur
nessun piano sopravvive mai al suo primo
incontro con il nemico e se ce lo dice
un comandante militare che fa piani
di guerra a tutti i giorni insomma no
prepara le truppe e ci dice che
attenzione che difficilmente quel quel
piano supererà il nemico supera la
realtà
allora dobbiamo dobbiamo riflettere su
questo tema c'è qualcun altro però che
ci dà un messaggio simile
ovviamente con uno stile diverso tutto
suo non stiamo parlando di un militare
non stiamo parlando neanche del global
ceo di una di una multinazionale
stiamo parlando di uno sportivo che ci
dice tutti abbiamo un piano finché
qualcuno non ci dà un pugno in faccia e
bel messaggio qui è chiaro è questi dice
attenzione mike tyson ci sta dicendo
quando poi il tuo piano fallisce la dura
realtà fa male fa male quasi come un
pugno di mike tyson insomma ci siamo
vicini
ma a questo punto nelle aziende voi lo
sapete no compiliamo file excel creiamo
piani aziendali
mi piace ricordare che per esempio il
excel è uno strumento estremamente
democratico
e sì perché qualsiasi numero che noi
andremo ad inserire nelle celle lui la
accetterà però la realtà è un'altra
a questo punto sembra scontata la
risposta alla domanda
abbiamo bisogno di un piano b
ci aspettiamo sì abbiamo bisogno piano b
prepariamoci il piano b invece secondo
me non abbiamo bisogno di un piano b sì
perché non abbiamo bisogno di una serie
di piani di backup piani secondario una
lista di piani alternativi
non abbiamo bisogno neanche di un
una rete di salvataggio qualora il piano
principale fallisca non abbiamo bisogno
di tutto questo perché ci toglierebbe
attenzione ed energie
nell'implementare la nostra strategia
provate a pensare se sapete di avere una
scappatoia o comunque di avere una via
d'uscita con quanta passione
andreste a implementare la vostra
strategia ma allora a questo punto cosa
abbiamo bisogno
abbiamo bisogno di una strategia con
diverse traiettorie
abbiamo bisogno di tre componenti tre
componenti essenziali per avere successo
nel mondo del lavoro e per raggiungere i
nostri obiettivi
il primo componente flexible planning
creare e pianifica pianificare in modo
agile i nostri piani al mutarsi delle
condizioni di mercato agli stimoli che
il mercato il consumatore ci danno ogni
singolo giorno perché il consumatore ci
dice esattamente quello che vuole e come
lo vuole però noi siamo intenti a
seguire la nostra strada seconda
componente
la cultura del cambiamento
sviluppare una cultura del cambiamento
che permetta alle aziende e ai manager
di improvvisare sì esattamente quello
che ci manca è improvvisare
intelligentemente
salutarsi delle condizioni infine
l'ultimo componente essenziale che
reputo essere più importante è accettare
il fallimento prova sbaglia e impara
sì perché il fallimento è parte
integrante del successo non potrai
vincere la sua sfida se prima non si è
passato attraverso
speriamo un solo fallimento beh spesso
sono più di uno il fallimento è parte
integrante di un processo di
apprendimento ha bisogno di fallire per
capire cosa funziona e cosa no la
capacità di evolvere e di cambiare ogni
giorno è il migliore piano b che tu
possa mai aver avuto grazie
[Applauso]